hello everyone and welcome to
today's webinar single cell spatial
phenotyping
fueling the next wave of discovery
biology
i'm christy jewel of labrutz and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by akoya biosciences
to learn more please visit akoyabio.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or maybe
hearing the presentation
i would now like to welcome our speakers
dr
jonah cool program officer
single cell biology chan zuckerberg
initiative
and dr oliver browba head of research
applications at okoya biosciences
for full biographies on our speakers
please click on the biography tab
at the top right of your screen welcome
jonah
you may now begin your presentation
great thank you very much introduction
and also
to the lab roots and nikoia team for
putting on this webinar it's really a
pleasure to be here and i'm excited to
very briefly share some of our work at
the chan zuckerberg initiative
and specifically the work of the team
that i lead focused on single cell
biology
um it will be a brief overview and so
just to reiterate the
moderator's encouragement to ask any
questions or please engage
uh really looking forward to the
discussion and hopefully digging into
some of these areas
in greater detail so let me start with
an overview in the mission statement of
the chan zuckerberg initiative science
initiative and
again we have a number of other
initiatives and would encourage people
to go to our website
and learn more about those as well as
some of the programs within the science
initiative that i won't have the time to
talk about so our mission is to support
science and technology
that will make it possible to cure
prevent or manage all disease by the end
of the century
this is obviously a very very lofty and
ambitious statement
and there's two things that i would like
to highlight that give us hope and
encouragement
and you know feel convicted that this is
indeed a mission that we
can accomplish as a group so the first
is the support of science and technology
and
my presumption here is that the interest
in this webinar is
that there are these new exciting and
foundational technologies that are
opening the door and shedding light
on important fundamental aspects of
science that are giving us
an ability to understand healthy and
also
specific diseases in new ways and
through new light
and that by working on these
technologies and deploying these
technologies advancing them and
sharing them with communities openly
there's the possibility to make
broad-scale changes that will advance
science and medicine in a non-linear way
so exponentially and that the end of the
century is still a long way away and so
there's
a lot of possibilities and opportunities
for this acceleration of progress
by making initial work and focus on
science and technology and so it's a
statement both about the importance of
fundamentals discovery and research
the role that technology has to play in
that discovery in research
and also the ability of us to make
unprecedented advances over the next
80 or so years we have a number of
active programs within the chan
zuckerberg initiative science
team these include very technology
focused efforts this is our work in open
science and imaging as well as more
disease
focused areas such as neurodegeneration
and again would encourage people to go
onto the website and learn more about
that
what i'm going to speak specifically
about is the work within the single cell
biology program
and within this group our goal is to
accelerate and support single cell
biology methods technologies and
applications
and the important thing here is that
level of resolution of the single cell
and that is really what we're focused on
so there
are a number of methods that have
emerged and are rapidly scaling as well
as
countless other opportunities to refine
and develop new methods
that provide insight into diverse
molecular features a spatial
organization of cells within intact
tissues
um that are really what we're interested
in supporting
and focusing on and so the the level of
resolution here is the thing that is the
common thread through the work that we
are supporting as well as some of the
tools that we are actively building
at the chan zuckerberg initiative to
hopefully help support
you and your work as well as others in
the field
so let me tell you briefly about the
current
opportunities and funding initiatives
and also some of the tools
that we are building so the chan
zuckerberg initiative is a unique
philanthropy
where we are both funding external
scientists such as many of you that have
joined today as well as building open
source tools that we hope
will support your work so these are
freely available and openly available
and are really intended to be used by
the community and so we are both
you know grateful and hopeful that they
will solve some problems
and challenges that you face but also
eager to hear your feedback and
understand how they might be able to be
evolved
so the first two areas here are active
areas
of funding within the single cell
biology program
the first is support for a large
international
uh community that is looking to build a
reference map of all the healthy cell
types in the human body and this is
the human cell atlas and i i think in
hope that many of you have heard about
this it's supported
by many funders around the world and
would encourage you to go to the human
slaughters website and you can register
and join that community for additional
updates
so here we are supporting data
generation efforts we have supported
computational methods and analytical
developments and benchmarking
and are really looking to support the
data generation the analysis
and the sharing of the human
healthy reference data sets in addition
to the to the reference data we are also
supporting some smaller initial programs
and pilots focused on single cell
analysis of inflammation
and so here is an opportunity to use
that reference data to use the tools
that are being developed
to support and generate that reference
data set but to begin to see how that
informs and changes our view of complex
biological processes
and diseases such as inflammation across
various tissues and diseases with the
goal
of understanding them at the single cell
level and ideally identifying pathways
and programs and cellular interactions
that are perhaps common and might inform
our view
of shared mechanisms or prioritize
targets
and then as i mentioned in addition to
those funding initiatives we are also
actively supporting and building tools
and for the rest of the talk i'll focus
on one of these
which is a data exploration tool called
cell by gene but also wanted to briefly
highlight another tool that we have
developed and is available to the
community
called starfish that is a analysis tool
for image-based transcriptomics or other
image-based assays including potentially
codecs it's been used in the past
and then also our support of the human
cell atlas data coordination
platform that is an effort to build a
cloud-based infrastructure to store and
serve
the data being generated by labs that i
mentioned at the top
um and again we'll briefly mention that
both all of
our i should say all of the groups that
we have supported for these first two
areas
as well as all of the resources that
they've generated whether it be
uh code or protocols or preprints or
data
are available and listed on our website
and we make an effort to keep that up to
date so please check that out for more
so let me now transition to an example
of one of those technology tools
that we have developed and are actively
developing it's called
cell by gene and the fundamental goal of
cell by gene is to develop
and make accessible a scalable
collaborative analysis tool
and so this hopefully reduces the
friction and enables
teams of researchers that are looking at
high dimensional and complex single cell
data sets to more easily collaborate
and understand and gain insight into
their data it is also
a hosted data publishing and exploration
platform so that
when groups are ready to share data and
especially as the demands on that data
grow
with growing data set size or complexity
that there is a hosted solution that is
free and available to researchers
it makes it easy for them to host takes
away the maintenance burden of some of
those portals
and similarly makes it easy to find data
and explore data
if you're looking to understand more
about a given tissue
or cell type or different questions that
would fuel your hypothesis
so what cell by gene looks like in this
workflow
is we have some support and scripts for
validating a common schema that's really
meant to provide
interoperability among these data sets
such that if there's
an interest in reuse of the data or
integration of multiple data sets
but hopefully the bar to that is lowered
and you were unable to do it
and so you can share your data and
validate it in this common schema we'd
be happy to talk a little bit about that
and also
answer questions offline if you're
interested in contributing data
and then it allows you to publish into
these collections which
are thematically linked it could be a
paper it also could be
a larger body of work that is maybe
associated with a given lab
or working group or anything like this
once the data is shared publicly
it then allows users to either
in the browser launch a exploration tool
and again this is very scalable so we
currently have data sets up to four
million cells that can be
viewed and differential expression can
be computed etc on different subsets of
the cells
but it can also be downloaded and the
download can be done in a number of
different
languages so you get the processed
matrices in that unified format in the
format of your choice hopefully to make
it very easy to pull it into whatever
downstream tool chain you're looking at
such as syrah or scanpi
or bioconductor so
this is what uh the collections look
like again you can go to the salvaging
website
and check out what is currently
available as i mentioned it can have
multiple different data sets associated
with a given collection
it can also have different types of data
so i want to highlight here there's an
example of a transcriptomic data a
proteogenomic data
so certainly protein information is
something that we're really eager to
adopt and work on and again very excited
to think about the possibilities
of working with more acquaintance codex
data as well as other data types so so
please check this out and let us know if
you have any questions
at the moment the the data resource
that's available
to anyone or any of you that are
interested
is about 36 collections this is probably
an underestimate actually the number
continues to grow
within those collections there's over
150 data sets and
now nearly 20 million cells worth of
data that are available
and also want to highlight this is not
just single cell transcriptomics it is
uh very diverse so seven different assay
types including functional assays like
patch seek
and as well as uh dissociated and
spatial assays
and this is the web or start the website
the email if you would like
to reach out about contributing data or
have questions
about any of the possibilities
so finally i wanted to emphasize that
the the flexibility of the tool so it
really will allow scalable exploration
of any matrix and so that certainly
includes a matrix that includes spatial
coordinates
so here are two quick examples of data
that is currently available
one was generated by the barcoding of
arrays and spatial transcriptomics and a
beautiful
paper published earlier this year from a
group in oxford and allison simmons
looking at fetal development of the gut
and another example of image-based
transcriptomics and there's a few of
these so this is an awesome fish data
set
that was published by stem liners lab in
sweden but also there is data available
for methods such as murfish and seek
fish and other methods
would would like to you know make the
point here that this is all
transcriptomics but again there's
nothing to say
that we can't uh work with protein data
and this is something that we're
actively pursuing
and would be available so if you have
those data sets and would like to
share them or explore them with cell by
gene please please reach out we'd really
like to
support you and would be excited to have
those available to the community
so with that i will end i will thank
everyone
these are a couple different links and
ways to get in touch
and stay abreast of the research and
work within cci
and cgi science as well as my personal
twitter handle
i will also mention that our team is
hiring if any of this work was inspiring
and
you would be excited to work on it
looking forward to the q a but before
that i
am uh excited and here to introduce
oliver who will take on the next section
so that all handed over to you oliver
thank you jonah um thanks for that intro
and thanks uh
nice information on the the cool stuff
that you guys are doing
um uh i met jonah obviously through this
czi work and i'm very curious to see
what
what our data will look like on this
platform as well
so um i'm the head of research
applications at akoya bioscience
and i must apologize in advance i went
to a karaoke bar last night to celebrate
the almost return back to normalcy
so i might have a sip of water here and
then seat my voice hose
but um what i would like to talk to you
about today is sort of
a follow-on to this idea of single cell
biology
evidently that's what we all aspire our
research
to get to today generate an atlas of the
entire human body and every cell
inside of it um and we're really
as we um accoya is a spatial biology
company so
we have this concept that we call single
cell spatial phenotyping i'm going to
explain to you how we see that based on
the codex experiment the codex
technology today now walk you through an
experiment first and then i'm going to
talk to you about how
this codec system works i'm going to
give you some some
um views on on on why it really matters
that
you have single cell resolution in your
experiment evidently
because we're doing single cell biology
so single cell spatial phenotyping is
is a concept um essentially where you're
doing phenotyping on
a whole tissue um and we have
unrestricted access to your tissue
meaning that you can see every cell
now a couple of things that you need for
that first of all
you need obviously a nice piece of
tissue what you can see here
is a piece of breast cancer tissue it's
rather large it's about two millimeters
from bottom to top
three point six millimeters from left to
right
and this particular image shows you that
breast tissue
stained with four different markers one
of them being a nuclear stain that beat
and the reason i always show this one up
front is because it it's really one of
my favorite snapshots that just shows
you
beautiful resolution so you can see
these cells here in blue we have the
adapting nucleus if you look somewhere
around the center some of these daffy
nuclei have a red ring around it that's
your nuclear envelope
and then outside of that there's a cyan
ring around that that's your plasma
membrane so not only do you have single
cell resolution actually
to some degree subcellular resolution
and when you're studying single cells
you know this might be perfectly obvious
to you
you need to see that you need to see
every single cell on your image
and by using optical microscopy for our
technology
in this case this is a codex experiment
that we image with an epi fluorescence
microscope that's a standard workflow
we ensure that every cell is seen so
that's a very important part
very important on parameter that we need
for
single cell spatial phenotyping next of
course is
you have to be able to label your tissue
with ample biomarkers
so you can see the same breast tissue
now and
the program is cycling through different
frames right now each of these frames
shows you that same tissue labeled with
five or seven different antibody
combinations
each one of these images tells its own
story
i remember 10 years ago when i was a
graduate student
i spent you know months and months
analyzing you know
threeplex images most of my publications
from back in the day were
you know what three colors two
antibodies three antibodies at the most
four
but today we work with up to 40
antibodies 42 antibodies even more
you just imagine how rich these data are
so you've just gone through that and
this breast tissue this is an experiment
where we did 36 biomarkers in a single
tissue so how do you register all this
information what do you do with all this
information how do you get to this
single cell spatial phenotyping result
so what you can see here is the same
tissue
has been now been segmented out into
all of every single cell essentially has
been registered
has been segmented and it also has a
color code in this case this color to
code um relates to the phenotype that
we've identified
so the way we read our data out the data
structure that you get
from codex experiment is like this you
can see this table here in the middle
the first column is your cell this
particular tissue slab that you see has
63
000 cells on it each cell is then
labeled with a combination of 36
antibodies ab1 ab2 and so on until you
get to 36.
each antibody or each cell bin has a
combinatorial labeling pattern which
makes it uniquely identifiable
these data are very similar to what you
would see coming out of a flow cytometer
or a single cell rna sequence experiment
you have a lot of cells a lot of
different biomarker patterns
what makes the codex data richer and
different is obviously that you also
have x y coordinates
you know exactly where every cell is and
that really is the gist of this
we know 63 000 cells are here they're
labeled very differently
and they're located precisely here and
here and there so that is really
really really important part obviously
of spatial biology
so if we go next um and see how we um
essentially go and analyze these data
what we do
um essentially just like you would in an
rna sec experiment we cluster our
data so you can see the output of the
clustering in this
round white area on the bottom left of
the screen that's a tisny plot
this twisty plot has different shades of
green yellow blue and red
so these shades show you different cell
phenotypes obviously
each dot on the disney plot is a single
cell
now it's important to know that every
one of these dots every single cell
remember is a cell that's on this
morphological image that's here in the
background
that means i can see the same cell on
the disney plot that i can see on my
tissue image that's immensely powerful
because often times when you work with a
technology where you don't actually see
yourself
saying for example you do sing i saw rna
sex or so we know they're there
we know pass through your sequencer we
know we know something sympathy just
it's always really a nice thing to be
able to go back to the tissue and say
oh there's my cell and here's a really
cool example of this
so after we clustered these results we
found
546 basal cells you can see that on our
right hand side here in the text
out of 63 000 cells there were 546 cells
that we identified at basal cells
that's less than a percent of the entire
population
44 cells were identified as a type of
aluminal cell so this is a type of
epithelium in a breast tissue
this is a very very rare cell type that
was first i think described by kai
kesembrox at uci
kai is actually a cgi researcher so
these data
are consistent with what he found and
this is a tiny little proportion of
the entire picture 0.07 percent
of the entire population of cells is
this type of luminal cell
so if you jump back over onto the tis
knee plot the very left hand side of the
tissue plot you can see this
red little island and from it is this
little tiny cluster of orange cells
so when i was first analyzing these data
i i thought this was noise i
didn't know what to make of this i had
no
you know i had no preconceived idea of
this tissue in the first place because
this is not my expertise
however it didn't really matter what we
tried to do this result always presented
itself these
orange little dots here you know 44
cells who cares
this is this must be noise but then
think about it and go
look up at this little white circle here
see those
three little orange cells right up there
those are actually those cells
so having the visual of your cells
seeing them
not only on your clustered data not only
on a heat map but actually on your
tissue
is probably one of the best validations
of your experimental data
the cells are there we can see them this
is not noise it's just an
incredibly rare cell type so that is
really
the power and the beauty of this single
cell spatial phenotyping business
you can look at thousands of cells half
a million so a million cells in a day
and you can even find the rarest cells
there are so
this big piece of breast cancer tissue
here you can see all of these little
orange dots
they sum up to about 44 of these cells
again this is less than one percentage
point on the entire cellular population
that was identified in a completely
unbiased way i would actually say
accidentally
using this codex experiment i'm a
neuroscientist
i study breast cancer tissue because i
needed a substrate to test my system
and essentially stumble across these
cells now once again
they've been described before in humans
by kai kestenbroek's lab
this was done completely independent of
what kai does but it led us to work
together actually which is um
on my story that happened here kai's
also working on codex now and i'll show
some of this data later
but it's really really a testament to me
that
the system is is reliable it's
incredibly sensitive
and it produces robust data so this is
an ex
a good example i like to lead in my talk
usually with this example
on how you know this single cell spatial
phenotyping works
and all of this was done with the codex
technology so i'm next going to give you
a very brief overview of how the
technology works
how the experiment is done
so codec system you can see that here on
the left hand side is essentially a
microfluidic device
it's this blue and white box and this
box connects
you can see via this tubing into an
epifluorescence imaging system so in
this case you see this gray and black
machine that's a cans bzx imager so
essentially that's an automated epi
fluorescence microscope
and the connection between the two is um
this fluidic stage so you can see the
stage
sitting in the middle of that cans is
connected via tube into your codex box
that's that's sort of your hardware and
your mechanics around it so codex really
is a microfluidic device
you can um pair that with a wide range
of epi fluorescence or even a focal
microscope so kians is probably the most
commonly used
at the time zeiss axioscopes um we're
seeing increased momentum with different
builds right now
um but that's the nice thing it's it's
essentially
it's it's designed to be plug and play
with optical images again we're relying
on optical imaging
this is a technology that's been around
for many many many years and has been
refined over and over again
to give us the optimal resolution now
the chemistry of codex
is really that's our product this is
where
the magic happens so if you look at the
um these three circles here and red blue
and yellow
let me just walk through this here this
circle is your tissue
and in the first step what you do you do
a one step staining of your tissue so
that means you take
all 40 or so antibodies that you have
you put them on your tissue all at once
incubate it tissue stains now each
antibody is labeled with an oligobar
code a unique
oligobar code so type your antibody one
will have oligotype one your antibody
number two will have oligo number two so
that that makes the
antigen detection distinct from one
another
once your tissue is labeled it actually
goes on to that codec stage
you close up your machine and the system
is automated from here on so you can go
home go to sleep
now what happens while you're at sleep
or in my case in the karaoke bar
the codex system takes fluorescent
reporters
and it does a cyclical imaging so where
if you now go from the red
from the red tissue state to the blue
tissue state
it will first identify three antibodies
so
what it does it dispense three
fluorescent reporters that are
complementary to oligos
on three antibodies the microscope then
takes a picture
you can see that little picture cycle
one underneath those um tissue images
that will be a representative 3m color
image from the first cycle
once that picture is acquired the codex
machine washes off the reporters
tissue reverts back and it's made of
state that's the red circle here
and then three different reporters are
put on the microscope takes another
picture that's a yellow thing here
and then that will be cycle two and it
repeats itself over and over again
until you've essentially read out all of
the antibodies that you label your
tissue with
um there's no stripping involved this is
an isothermal reaction
this is automated and the reagents are
all inventoried so you can buy most of
this stuff off the shelf you don't have
to mix stuff you have to come up with
recipes it's extremely convenient
right now at the moment if you were
going to do this experiment
you have access to 42 barcodes um which
means you can put on 42 antibodies
with tendency increasing so we're we're
expanding our barcode menu because we
realize people want to see more and more
and more different
outputs so that's essentially how this
works it's a cyclical
um ihc where um you label your tissue
with
inventory reagents and um essentially
very clean
you don't have a lot of cross-reactivity
because you're not using secondary
antibodies
and that's a very very nice thing about
this but i'm just going to come back
once more one more time full circle
under this idea that
this is a whole tissue imaging
experiment
meaning that whatever tissue you can fit
on onto the coverslip that we use
you can image that in its entirety it's
up to you as a user what you're going to
image and you have single cell
resolution
and i just want to say a few words why
you know why we think that this is very
very important
so here again we're returning to the
same breast tissue
that i've talked about before this is
just dappy
but i love this image i just think it's
beautiful you can see
these different areas here of like
hyperplasia or
swollen regions this is not a healthy
looking tissue but
again we're seeing every single cell so
if you're used to
taking images that be this is what you
expect to see
it's a single cell resolution of a very
large piece of tissue
now if you look around a lot of the
technologies that are available today
they actually depend on roi based
imaging approaches
so rather than imaging a whole tissue
um the systems they need predefined
grades of rois or the users select
certain rois because the technology only
allows them to look at so much structure
substrate at once there are of course
many reasons for that this is
by design mechanical or or analytical
this is just how some of these systems
work
and what's really astounding about these
approaches
is that you actually end up losing a
whole bunch of data
so let's just go back quickly this here
is a whole tissue breast
you know whole breast tissue you can see
there's a lot of biology going on
there's a lot of regionality i mean
there's something very different
this particular region than say this
packed region of epithelia so there's
you know there's so many different
layers that you can slice this and see
different things
but now let's go to an roi based imaging
approach
you cannot really make out any of this
regionality anymore all you have is a
bunch of rois with cells inside of them
and we did some modeling here so we
overlaid codex data on just a grid that
for example you would use in a spatial
transcriptomics experiment
and we find that you lose up to 49 of
your data with some of the original
designs
again this is you know this is done by
necessity or by
by the nature of the technology but the
fact is that
you you end up losing a fair bit of data
and if you think about it even further
a lot of the technologies today that
we're using for for spatial biology
experiments don't actually have single
cell resolution
so now you cut out 49 of your data
because you do an roi
based imaging approach but what i've
done now is i actually blurred each one
of these circles
by the diameter of how big these circles
are so assuming you have an
uh a technology where you're imaging 50
micron diameter
rois without single cell resolution
you end up really compressing your
signals down
averaging your signals out a whole lot
so essentially what you see right now
are
fuzzy spots really that's what it is um
so
the question at this point is what
remains you know is this
actually still single cell biology um
in my mind it is not i mean and i'm
going to give you an example
as to i i really like this example but
i'll give you an example that hopefully
it illustrates to you
very clearly that it's very very
important that we do indeed see
every cell so here i've juxtaposed this
roa roi based approach versus
a non-roi based approach to analyzing
data so on the left hand side
you can see a signal for cd34
and what we're doing here and this is
just codex data just a single antibody
channel it's not cleaned up you can see
all kinds of fuzz here
in this sort of bluish little tiny spots
but
cd34 is a label for the vasculature and
vasculature
you know there's a long tube so you can
see these strings
here on the left hand side all over
they're like short strings and long
strings fat strings
thin strings that's what the blood
vessels look like though that is your
vasculature
so without knowing too much about you
know
what i don't know without even caring
about the vasculature frankly
you can see where it is you know where
the arteries are you know where the
capillaries are
you could probably see a broken vessel
now if you look at the right hand side
these colored dots here are the
intensity readouts for the very same
signal
so that's your cd4 pattern right there
you can see a few orange spots you can
see some dark blue spots
you probably can say oh there may be a
blast light so there and there's
certainly not a blood vessel in the dark
blue spot
but you're missing on it a lot of
granularity
if i was going to ask you you know where
do you think you know
the capillary is versus the art of
arterial or
i don't think this is is really possible
here so i think
to me it really i appreciate
the importance of you know not let's say
compressing your data down for the
expense
of gaining something else i think it's
really really important that when we do
these types of experiments especially
when they're single cell biology
experiments
that we maintain this information and
that is really what
the power of this not just a codex
experiment but
any spatial biology technology that is
using
optical microscopy to reveal these
signals so just to compare once again
we're looking at the same tissue
it's about four by two millimeter breast
tissue sixty three thousand single cells
were mapped with codecs
now if you break this down into rois
with about ten cells per
um roi you have about 14 to
1400 different roi so those are 14
points of analysis versus 63 000 it's
quite a difference
both of them are looking at the same
thing cd34
the conclusion here really is on the
left hand side
which is a codex experiment you're doing
single cell spatial biology
you could tell me where the blood
vessels are the right hand side
this is what i would call this a spatial
approximation
you see yeah okay there's a
regionalization there's some blood
vessels here and there
but that's about as much as you can say
and i think
there are there are a lot of purposes
for both of these technologies
um they're probably more complementary
than anything
but it's very important to have this
distinction especially when you're
new to this field and you're planning to
do this type of an experiment
what is it that you want do you want to
do single cell spatial phenotyping or do
you want to approximate the space
i think this is a question everyone
needs to ask themselves in the very
beginning
both things are possible today i think
the end goal will always be to do single
cell biology
we all know this this the cvi stated
goal
is to study every single cell so it's a
choice is easy from here on
so let's move on to a little different
topic then
so now i talk to you about you know what
this experiment looks like
and you know kind of going back and
forth with you know
what data structure is i'm gonna just
talk a little bit about what you can do
with these data now
um because i think there's probably a
lot of you have worked with um single
cell rna sex i just want to
point out some of the similarities in
the data and then
give you sort of an idea where we think
the field is going to be going
soon and and the title for this section
is phenotype
metrophenol space so um i think this is
the first time i've said this in public
phenol space and
that term's already been used for
something for a completely different
type of research but what i'm trying to
get to here is that
we all talk about single cell
phenotyping today but one of the things
that we at akoya are really starting to
appreciate is this idea of contextual
cell phenotypes
a phenotype is sure it's the id of a
cell
but what if you put that cell somewhere
else like
imagine yourself you know being at home
on your couch are you the same person
who's sitting in his office his or her
office wearing you know
professional attire or so we think the
same thing happens to a cell
whether or not the cell is sitting at
home on its couch or if it's gone into
the wrong place like a tumor
the cell would kind of have the same
phenotype but is it gonna be behaving
the same way
and so that's that's what we think a
contextual phenotype would capture and
really probably this is the next
frontier in my mind where um single cell
biology
should and will go so this is an
experiment that we
together with kai um again he's at uci
and he's a cgi investigator this is um
one of the first experiments that he did
we did this on last year and once again
this is breast tissue and
it's just gorgeous this tissue so what
we did in this experiment we labeled the
tissue with 32
antibodies there's on this particular
image there are 81 000 cells
it's pretty large it's six by eight
millimeters
and you can see sort of these these
round things here these are one type of
epithelium
that's a secretory epithelium that's
where the fluids are generated and then
you have these
long lines these are actually tubes and
so that's where the the fluids will be
collected
and you'll notice there's a whole bunch
of black space around all this
that's actually all fat and connective
tissue
we didn't put any markers for fat or
connective tissue labels on there
but it just i love this image because it
illustrates the luxury
that we have a codex think about having
an roa
roi based imaging approach like would
you waste your rois
on fat tissue we don't care because we
can just image the whole tissue
takes a little bit more time but now you
know of course
you know kai is asking of course now oh
what's in the fat so he's getting
interested in that but
having access to whole tissue imaging is
it's it's
it's a luxury but again it's necessary
or understand what's going on so what we
do with this
breast tissue is label there were 32
markers segmented out each cell
and then we essentially we break it down
so we can get heat maps for every single
marker in this experiment and so you can
see bcl2
is expressing um in red so this is your
top left marker here on the very
top you can see when it's red there's a
lot of expression for it and blue it's
called
if you go so for example to the very
bottom left there's tp63
that's a marker for basal cells
predictably expressed
throughout the epithelium sometimes you
get markers that don't really
do what they're supposed to um like this
is immunohistochemistry you'll always
get non-specific binding and so
these types of analyses really help you
pick this out it's a
fantastic way to not only represent your
data but to do qc and see what's going
on
and then on top left you can see a yuma
of your cluster
data all of this is um done in an
end-to-end analysis solution
and it allows us to oops sorry it allows
us to very quickly
um quantify your different cell types so
you can see we quantified
about a dozen different cell types here
we have a lot of luminal cells type of
epithelium
that's that orange pi um square you have
basal cells
a smaller population of cells and so on
and so forth all of these cells were
expected to be there
um so if codex experiment works really
really nice for breast tissue
so once you have all your cells
segmented and phenotype and annotate it
this is really where the exciting stuff
begins so
this is where you know i say you know
phenotype meet your phenospace
so here you can see about 10 different
phenotypes
cd4 cells cd8 cells dendritic cells
mapped out on top of the actual
architecture of this tissue
so each one of those cells has now
become a dot with phenotype
that's what it looks like if you look a
little bit closer
you can see these dots a little bit
better so we've become really interested
in this idea of mapping the connectivity
between every single cell in your image
and that's what these lines here
demonstrate so these are triangulations
essentially
just you know trying to figure out what
the shortest distance between any
three neighbors are when you do this
type of an experiment essentially you
can draw a line from every single cell
to every single other cell on your
tissue
you're just generating a lot of a lot of
data so it becomes very
interesting or very complicated trying
to understand what's going on here
and one of the concepts that we've been
excited about and that's sort of come
out
in recent months has been this idea of
neighborhood analyses
so i'm going to walk you through one of
these
so assuming we're interested in cd4
t cells you can see that on sort of in
the middle column and these little
cartoons here there's a cd4 t cells are
red
in this image and there's one t cell in
the middle in each one of these images
what we had the computer do is we
interrogated the entire breast tissue
and we said
now take a look at every cd4 t cell and
and you know
break it up into different neighborhoods
what do the surroundings of these
t cells look like and when you do this
the computer comes up with different
patterns
and it gives you sort of an idea that
there are certain parts of the tissue
where a t cell is more likely to be next
to other t
cells as you can see in this series of
cartoons
than in other parts of the tissue so i
just made another cartoon here
now you can see these little t cells
they're no longer surrounded by
you know the same type of cell but
instead they're actually surrounded by
epithelial basal cells
so you can see the t cell in red and
there's all kinds of yellow cells around
it
so now we've done you know this is this
is just the way the tissue is we're just
taking an objective look at it and
it's sort of a clustering based
algorithm we're looking throughout the
entire tissue
trying to figure out where the um
different cells will be here
and you can just i just wonder when i
look at this i'm like what
what does t cd4 t says in cluster one
how would they behave compared to the
cd4 t cells in cluster six
or if we just take this analysis further
and we look for example at luminal cells
you can see nine different clusters for
these luminal cells the luminal cell
here will be the brown cell
each one of these rows shows you
different environment in which a luminal
cell can exist so look at cluster one
you have a little brown cell surrounded
by cd4 t
cells always let's look at question
number
four you have luminous cells that are
somehow associated with lymphatic
vessels
cluster number seven luminal cells next
to dendritic cells you go on and on
now these are all luminal cells by
phenotype
but every one of these um phenotypes of
every one of these cells has a different
neighborhood
so this is i think a concept that is
really emerging now
and gary nolan grandfather this just
came out at the end of last year
this idea of cellular neighborhoods and
what they've shown in that paper and i
think it's really great paper i
encourage anyone
who's interested in this to read through
this first and then go from there
is that these types of patterns matter
so
they looked at colorectal cancer samples
with two different types of colorectal
cancer with different outcomes
and they show really nice correlations
between
certain types of neighborhood being
present in the tumor and stromal
areas and the actual outcome of
of what these diseases are so when the
phenotypes meet
phenospace the cells behavior probably
changes
these are things that we need to be
aware of because they
they seem to actually have clinical
manifestations they seem to matter in
the larger scale
in the larger picture so we're hyper
aware of this right now and
of course by having single cell whole
tissue resolution
we are very much able to actually
interrogate these types of phenomena
and it's very um new i think not even
not so new anymore but uh
this is a more and more growing field
and i'm very excited
that um we're working on this and you'll
probably hear a lot more about this
going forward
so this was sort of a a bit of a deeper
dive into codex data
and now i'm just going to sort of
conclude my
section with a few case studies i'm
going to try to hit a few
frequent questions that i get about what
can you actually use codex for
um and i'll just give you the answer
right away
really any tissue you can image in in
theory any tissue that you can image and
do ihc on you should be able to do codex
on
because it is ihc so
immunohistochemistry i mean
and let's just walk through a few of
these and so
recent months we spent a lot of time
actually working on brain tissues
so this is a collaboration with with dr
bihari ajami
at the oregon health science institute
um very interesting um
tissues that we have here but what you
can see here is is
a piece of human brain tissue formal and
fixed paraffin embedded
highly autofluorescent tissues most
people
think you cannot really do clean imaging
on these tissues but there are ways to
do that with codex
it revolves autofluorescence removal and
then subsequent imaging but as you can
see here it's just
gorgeous staining so in blue you can see
amyloid plaques
this is sort of a pathological
manifestation of alzheimer's disease
and in red you can see glial cells these
glial cells are
like um surrounding these plaques and
then in green there are nuclei
now of course you can label the single
tissue with 42 different antibodies so
you can start to interrogate the
immune micro environment of alzheimer's
really nicely
so you can see in these little images
that i just popped up here
each time it's iba one so eba one
so in red this is actually what's called
microglia
so i guess for those of you who are not
neuroscientists um think of a microglia
as something like a macrophage of the
brain
and they have different activation
states so on the left hand side you can
see ebay one that's co-labeled with team
m119
so these these will be presumably active
as they're associated with this blue
big protein plaque there must be a lot
of action here
if you look over on the right hand side
you have the same cells labeled with
different immune markers once again
shown activation states really nice
to see this work together and now if you
have any 40 markers you wish to put on
here and study these tissues in more
detail
it's possible to do so so we're very
excited about that
very common question that we always get
is can you actually image tissue
microarrays um
yeah the answer is yes you may um it's
the same really as as for a larger
tissue
you just need to be able to fit them
under the cover slip so you can see here
this is a tissue microarray um that we
got from dr patrick mickey
uh in uppsala and these are all um
lung adenocarcinomas i think the entire
microwave that we imaged at the time had
50 cores or so on it
and i'm just showing a fraction of these
but again these were labeled with codecs
with you know
two dozen antibodies or so now suddenly
you have a large sample size in addition
to all of these biomarkers this is
really cool like you have
all these individual patient tissues
with the same set of you know
you know 24 or 30 different biomarkers
imagine how much data
is contained within that one single
experiment it's a lot like i spent
you know weeks just sitting over these
data and seeing things and so it's
really exciting
um we've done work in neuronal cultures
um and organoids so the nice thing here
is especially with
cell cultures you can grow them up right
on our cover slip
that's what we've done i'm with dr
schule at stanford university
um so they cultured neurons right on top
of our cover slip
and then we took that cover slip we
fixed the neurons and we ran a codex
experiment with it and
the neurons don't peel off they don't
fall off they just stay there
um you can see that right here so this
is a snapshot from one of these cultures
in green you have glial cell yellow you
have neurons
and then in cyan you can sort of see
stringy patterns here
this is certain markers for neuronal
filaments
so really nice tissues a really nice
versatility of the system and my summary
slide then would just be this you know
can i use codex
for yeah really any tissue that you can
be imaged
so just this last year in our lab you
know
we've seen melanoma brain tissue lung
tissue
skin gut kidney even
even blood cells with image by fixing
them on a cover slip in the breast we
talked a lot about and spleen
i should add here that this works of
course for mice and
for human tissues it works for fresh
frozen and ffpe um really anything
um that people work on nowadays for ihc
seems to work quite well with this
system
so um it shouldn't be um a question of
of what it's just you know when so with
that
i'm going to conclude my section of the
talk
and i'd like to thank you for your
attention and if you want to
hear more about codex or our fan optic
system which i didn't have time to talk
to you about today
visit our website at akoyabio.com and
i'm looking forward to the q a now
and i think there's a lot of interesting
questions pouring in
so i'll hand the mic over again
thank you oliver and jonah both for your
excellent presentations
and yes it is now time for our live q a
portion of the webinar
as a reminder to our audience if you
have any questions you would like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box
type in your questions and click send we
do have a lot of great questions that
have already come in so let's get
started
let's go with this one um let's start
with andrew's question
a very cool presentation it sounds like
your team at akoya performed codex
imaging and codex data analysis for kai
is this something akoya is offering to
other investigators
or industry partners
i guess i will take that question here
um
so kai is a
collaborator of ours he works together
with us
and we have many collaborations of
course with
both academic investigators and industry
partners
we get um we have a technology access
program for
codex it's called step um where we do
both experiments in the wet lab and dry
lab analysis with with really anyone
um so it's possible to get our attention
for sure for collaborative purposes the
best way to do that is to come in
through our tech access program
which is called steps so um you can
acquire that any any one of our reps
thank you oliver jonah let's go to you
for this next question
most of the single cell funding
opportunities posted by czi are limited
to normal tissues when will cgi be
announcing
new opportunities for diseased tissue
that's a great question and and that is
absolutely right so historically
within the single cell program the vast
majority of our
rfas and grant funding has gone to
normal tissue
i would go back and highlight the maybe
two things
one that i spoke about one that i did
not first was the inflammation program
which was launched last year
those are relatively short initial um
projects so two years in duration
and it's really our hope and um ambition
that those
grow and lead to additional funding
opportunities so
you know we don't have any of those
active right now but certainly
um hope to see our our work and support
of that area grow in time the other that
i would highlight
is the neurodegeneration challenge
network
opportunities and there there are a
number of groups using
single cell methodologies many of them
are you know very very interested
in spatial organization and you can
imagine the importance of these sorts of
questions for example
in relation to the immune system and its
interactions
with plaques for example so that is
also another program that they didn't
touch on that is cci related
and in both cases we also um encourage
people to reach out with disease data if
it's
interesting to them to use cell phones
so again that
platform is available both toward greece
but also to anyone else
and for example a large number of groups
have used or contributed data um to help
disseminate
and make uh work on cobit go more
accessible so there that's one area
where we're absolutely
supporting disease work and i think that
there will be many more funding
opportunities
for the world and our generation program
great question
great thank you jonah okay for our next
question it's two parts
to what extent can the phenotyping
panels be customized
for example if i wanted to differentiate
cell types within kidney tissue and i
know the markers i'd like to test for
would it be possible to generate an
assay that i could use to test tissue
from
say a wild type mouse versus a
mouse with a genetic modification
yeah sure i'm happy to answer that
question so um
the phenotyping panels actually at the
moment are fully customizable
we have um inventoried antibodies that
you can choose from in a catalog
so just you know many many antibodies
that are already pre-configured to be
used for codecs
a lot of immune markers a lot of you
know structural markers
of some encode genes and it depends
really what you're interested in
so you can buy those off the shelf but
really the customization
that um that will be then of interest to
you is all of the antibodies that you
already are interested in that in some
cases you have in the lab
you can actually chemically modify them
that is
conjugate them to our barcodes so let's
say you're working on two dozen
antibodies that
do not exist yet in a codex inventory
that's not a problem at
all that just means that you buy the
conjugation kit you perform the
conjugation yourself or you get it in
through our technology access
program where the conjugation can be
done and you build your entirely custom
panel
so every reagent that you need to
generate a fully custom panel
is available to you there really aren't
any limitations there
so yeah you can anything you want you
can look at kidney and mouse you can
look at kidney and human disease normal
you have to make the design and you're
good to go
thanks oliver and a quick question again
for you do you track
single cells
yeah that's what i just said for the
last half hour that's that's all we do
that's our bread and butter
everything is single cell very good
thank you for the clarification
our next question is this frozen section
or a fppe tissue section
the large majority of the tissue that i
show today were ffpe tissue sections in
human
um except for the cell culture image at
the very end that was a
that wasn't even frozen that was life
fixed so ffpe works really well
thank you how long does it take for a
full panel of 40 antibodies to run
through
and will you be covering data analysis
in this presentation
um that's a good great question i
so the 40 antibodies it takes a fair bit
of time but it really depends on how big
your tissue is
so if you're only looking at you know a
small you know
400 by 400 micron tissue
you probably run it through and in less
than a day but if
we have a lot of people who are running
really large pieces of tissue let's say
10 by 10 millimeters on 40 antibodies
that can take i can almost take two days
um
or you know it's 36 hours so it's a
factor of how large your tissue is
because the imaging happens in tiling
manner it's a sort of a cereal process
plus how many antibodies you have more
antibodies you have the larger your
tissue is the longer it takes
and with regards to the second part of
your question about covering the
analysis
i did not cover how the analysis done
i've shown some example
of what can be done we have a lot of
webinars on our website on how analysis
can be done
i encourage you to look at those if
you're interested we did quite a few
sort of
tech talks in the last few years and so
there's a ton of information in
in the literature and webinar section of
our website
thank you let's go with this next
question is microbiome
included in the human cell atlas
yeah i can take that one so it's an
interesting question the short answer is
it's certainly not at the core but for
many tissue types
and especially barrier tissues there is
of course
an appreciation that the microbiome is a
key factor in those neighborhoods and
the cellular
interactions that that oliver touched on
and has some beautiful images for
so i i think the answer is that it's not
necessarily the core but certainly
within the czi
funded groups that are working on
developing and contributing data to the
human solace
it is certainly an assay that some of
those
uh an assay and data type that some of
those groups are collecting and
measuring so for example
um certainly within the airway and gut
and places like this
so it's it's a little bit of a
wishy-washy answer but in in some cases
it is and we would hope that all of that
data would be associated and linked but
certainly not true
of all of the organs and tissue types
thanks jonah our next question
is phenotyping solely based on
thresholding of biomarkers
signal intensities
um at the moment phenotyping is solely
based on
thresholding not always thresholding but
um cataloging biomarker intensity
um yes it's um at the moment that's
that's the main method
but we're exploring other ways of doing
it because you can
there's quite a few different aspects
refining especially with cancer cells
and nuclei have very different shapes
and immune cells so
the the main tool and it's always been
like that
that's it's consistent with other
platforms is to to
record in threshold biomarker intensity
but we're finding more and more
since we have the the resolution and we
can see
you know individually we can see the
shapes of nuclei the sizes to geometry
we're exploring ways to add those
factors on top because it gives us a
much more granular understanding of
phenotypes and the results are much
cleaner
so this is a i would say that's actually
a rapidly developing space
thank you now we have time for a few
more questions so let's squeeze some in
there
how about can this technology allow
quantitative comparison between disease
versus normal
it should absolutely uh um it's
any comparison can be made uh you
we so we've done a lot of this work um
with our phenomx platform
um that says standard experiment there
and with codex i've seen
more and more people are doing a lot of
quantification of phenotypes so
for example there are more t cells in
one type of cancer than another
so these comparisons are absolutely
possible
um and and it's becoming routine
actually to
to start working on these
thank you and while we're speaking of
phenotypes let's go with this question
how do you see codex and other types of
multiplex spatial data
becoming standardized across modalities
and platforms
around shared definitions of cell
phenotypes and phenospaces
i think that's a great question uh i
don't exactly know how it's going to
happen but i am i'm an advocate for that
it must happen
um so codex is is is
the new kid on the block here it's only
been around for two years or so
um but already there's an interest for
from several
um from several big groups to achieve
parity and standardization across sites
for example
we know that the human tumor atlas
network is quite actively pursuing
these types of standardizations for
cross-platform
so work is being done right now actively
across
the spectrum to try and see first
question obviously is
where do what is parity how do we define
it when can we get it
and then the standardization is probably
the next one
i should also add that other
technologies such as multiplex
immunofluorescence which um
we we call fanoptics at akoya it's
already
reached a level of standardization that
it does very good
um so it's it's happening and i i hope
that um
we come to the consensus in the
community very soon it really depends on
the
on the community at large to to drive
this um we have of course at aquaria
have a big responsibility to push this
forward and we take this issue very
serious
i would chime in on that one and echo
oliver's comments as well this is
something that's really important to us
and
also have enjoyed and appreciated the
the commitment and excitement about this
that the akoya team has
and so i think it is very much a
community-based one and will take
you know collaboration and openness
among the groups generating the data and
the companies that are enabling that
as well as you know opportunities and
willingness to share data and
interoperable formats and
common panels and things like this but
really really important problems that
we all will have to work on in the
coming years
great thank you both and we have time
for one last question
we'll wrap with this one what was the
objective you used for
many of your images
uh most of the images you saw today was
just done with the standard 20x lens
um the reason for using a 20x is that
we like the whole tissue imaging
approach so if when you're imaging a
you know a 10 millimeter by 10
millimeter tissue
it's it's it's just more economical to
work with the 20x and we get what we
want out of a 10ex
so what you saw today was a 20x
non-immersion
uh you can work with 40 actually
obviously the resolution is even better
the granularity is better the
phenotyping is cleaner
it just takes much longer time to map
these big tissue parts so
we have both lenses in regular use
depends on what your question is some
people use codex to look at a restricted
area
say for example they want to look at
transcription factors or
you know even nowadays like synaptic
terminals
that's obviously a 40x workflow but
everything i've shown you today is that
it is large
tissue whole tissue analysis is easily
done on a 20x
thank you both for this excellent q a
session i do want to remind our audience
that there were quite a few questions
that we did not have time to answer
today
those ant questions will be answered via
email
to the email address that you provided
at the time of your registration
i also want to mention that this
presentation is available for unlimited
on-demand viewing we will also be adding
a
link into our on-demand
studio that will allow you to reach out
and provide any feedback ux
insights on sell by gene so please
come back for the on demand to view that
link
i want to thank dr cool and dr browba
one more time for their
excellent presentations today and the
very informative q a
session if you missed any portion of
today's
webinar just a reminder you can come
back and watch it on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event and then as a
reminder today's presentation is
educational and it does offer continuing
education
credits please click on that continuing
education credits tab
and follow the process to obtain your
credit thank you so much for joining us
today
have a great day